malgré tout les manoeuvres des manuels
macron pour faire monter les extrêmes
les républicains sont là sont présents
et on voit bien que nous sommes
aujourd'hui le seul vote utile une
opposition utile qui sera jamais dans
les outrances nez dans les excès mais
qui sera déterminée pour voter a demandé
des réformes qui pourraient aller dans
le bon sens et pour s'opposer durement à
celle qui rompt un contresens de ce que
l'on ce que l'on souhaite de ce qui est
souhaitable pour le pays sur notre
position elle est conforme à la ligne
qui a toujours été celle de notre
famille politique
aucune voix sur l'un d'eux doit se
porter sur les extrêmes